[Music]
for five years
a team of marine scientists has been
traveling the world in search of
the most incredible corners of the oceans
where the balance between nature and
the changing environment has not yet
reached a national critical point
geographic which is dedicated to
discovering these places and
sharing them with the world so that we
can protect them for future
generations
the reefs moving away from
new caledonia promised to
be one of the most primitive on our planet
but  the poverty of our knowledge
of the place led us
to take a closer look at this
ecosystem 1200 km east of australia
in the heart of the coral sea new
caledonia has everything from a tropical paradise
in november 2013  we traveled
to the capital city of noumea to embark
on an expedition to the
remote reefs of new caledonia what
little information we had
hinted that these reefs may  it is
one of the rare oceanic places
still wild after many months of
planning several weeks of
preparation and days of travel our
team is getting underway
in collaboration with the university of
new caledonia the
research institute for development and the
project  more teenage reefs led by
laurent villiot there we have assembled
a team of
international specialists from france spain the
united states and new caledonia
our first destination the
chesterfield islands an archipelago of small islets
and recife 550 km to the north  west of
mainland the main island of
new caledonia
for our team the time had come
to concentrate
but impatience was contagious
with each new expedition we take
a fresh look at what surrounds us
and try to answer our questions
how healthy are the reefs
of caledonia
what life forms are we opening up in
this place
discovering the answer stimulates us
he can't consult the website
or books to learn more
[Music]
the only solution is to go there
and observe it for ourselves
for us it's science pure exploration
[Music]
saleh
on our first morning at sea
we were all eager to dive in
matches number 9
[Music]
m
that's it
these waters will turn out to be such a stage and
overflowing with life
or happy with other corners of
the  discover in us an ecosystem
of picture rails
[Music]
this answer will guide our expedition
it
[Music] a
few moments were enough to
confirm that we were indeed in the
presence of an intact reef
the landscape was a carpet of corals
we were in the heart of  a garden full
of life
[Music]
m
ether schools of fish
[Music
] crabs
sea snakes
[Music]
the inhabitants of these waters were as
magnificent as they were diverse
[Music]
the presence of certain  s of
the most powerful predators of the supers having been
for us a clear sign that this
ecosystem was doing well
[Music]
towards the end of our dive
we discovered with surprise that
we were not the only ones enthusiastic
about this place
[Music]
sea turtles take advantage of the scenery to ma
e and lay their eggs we th
ught we were in burgundy but don't say that they
otably fell [Laug
s] our d
y ended with a lot o
hope for the next few weeks
we knew without  shadow of a
doubt being in the presence of intact recife
what other surprise does new
caledonia have in store for us tel
[Music]
in these waters the seascape is
dotted with small islets and atolls
formed by the gradual erosion of
coral over millennia
a priori it seems desert
night
isolated areas in a submerged world
but a closer examination
reveals an ecosystem as fascinating as
that which hides under the waves
[Music]
a turtle  similar to those
encountered under water has come to lay
her eggs
[Music]
she carefully digs a false
task which can take several hours
[Music]
I
once satisfied she will take up to
120 years
once her task is accomplished she leaves
leaving  small enough the care of surviving
once is closed hatching which will take place
in the next few months
the turtles are not the only ones on
these shores
the seabirds of
new caledonia large predators of
the sea
also take refuge on land do
[  Music]
the proximity of the reefs provides a rich
supply of small fish and an
ideal environment to start a
family
the birds take their own eyes
sometimes only a few meters
from turtle nests and raise their young
[Music]
to
the fears of these deals are  on the lookout
for brand new where sharon who would cross
their path the large predators
thus becomes the prey of small steps hard
[Music]
da  ns healthy ecosystems like
this each species has a role to play
[Music]
these territories nothing to recruit
grains of sand for our satellites are
essential oases between sea and air
north of the chesterfield islands
we are setting out to discover the
entrecasteaux reefs of petri
and astrolabe
[Music]
our vice up to now had been
encouraging
but we had to consider the possibility
that these other remote areas were
not as healthy or productive
[Music]
all our doubts arose  erased in an
instant
[Music]
everywhere our gaze landed
it was only bright colors of
curious fish in our presence
[Music]
thus clearly showing the
little human interaction on their
territory
[Music]
the abundance and diversity of  life
was breathtaking
where
[Music]
to discover so many marine species in
one place was a
concrete vision of what the ocean must have been like
and what  'he could become if he
were protected
[Music]
towards the end of our dive
a great hammerhead shark appeared in
front of us
so interested in us that we
let him
[Music]
caracas
[Laughs]
the number of  sharks and predator
was excellent proof of reef health
in an area super exploit large
predators are disappearing which can
harm the eco system as a
whole one of the most incredible dives of
the expedition
to show the  great presence
of predators in its under
[Music]
at least fifty gray reef sharks
gathered near the surface
this scene could frighten many
people
but for us it was an
absolutely magnificent sight
[Music]
these sharks were synonymous with an
ecosystem  flourishing
so far our
compressed air cylinders decided the depth of our
dives
[Music]
At the petri reef we decided
to use our en ovi a gear which
p  We had to go down to 200 m
and we saw a high resolution video
on the surface
[Applause]
allowing us to discover the
waters of new caledonia more
deeply
[Music]
mancini yes
an absurdity
[Music]
guitarist ry
during the piloting of the orlovi by
steve we observed the screens as the
images reveal another world to us
even at these depths the coral of
new caledonia is flourishing shaft
collonges the rise thanks to the
local mako figures
the speech
do not hesitate during the descent  du rau
life an impressive variety of
marine life welcome us
agreements
[Music]
need
respect
[Music]
yes
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the life halo has allowed us to
collect valuable data  on the deeper waves
but we couldn't wait to get back
underwater and the astrolabe reef
was one of the places that inspired us a
lot  sooo
good that
mo
[Music]
this weekend
below the surface
the astrolabe is as amazing as
we hoped
[Music]
a large school of parrot fish a
boss greeted us at the reef these
fish are classified as vulnerable
[Music]
but here they are everywhere
we saw several huge
gorgonians charts
[Music]
a unicorn fish
for marine science specialists and advocates
this dive
was a dream come true
[Music]
beam  web profile in time for thought it
with death is absolutely one of the most
for hugo observers from the government
of new caledonia
this dive was of particular importance
zapatero from itunes 10 videos
published by chiquitos the meeting
these rains
good marks in its spots for  new
caledonia we have
phishing activities can't catch all this
just in time to appear
à copé and some things are hoping to be
destroyed
[Music]
n
towards the end of our expedition
[Music]
we received good news we
had received special permission to
visit or v to one of the loyalty islands to
the east of mainland
a unique opportunity to discuss our
findings
during  our trip most important
yet to hear their perspective
on the preservation of their area
with its importance
to ouvea many people
still use traditional fishing methods which are
both effective and
sustainable
here makes it stand out the reef is
owned by the community
[Music]
it
's instead of being passed
[Music]
bing
the mind of the sights on his companion in
the tories we helped from a vehicle
to a prison cache it's
mostly collective expression
and here is what we saw in new
caledonia is that i the places which
are very long they are very
well preserved but also we had a
lot of interest in talking with you and
knowing your way of managing  er
the fishing resource that is to say and that is
why for me personally see
his photo to you today if you
come from everywhere and you also have the
concern of trying to save our
heritage
the people who live so thank you thank you
to determine if for us it was
obvious that we had the same
objectives for the islanders the health
of the ocean is more than an attraction
it is a necessity
we received the authorization to
dive in the waters surrounding the island
[  Music]
it's diving will be the last of our
expedition the perfect conclusion to an
absolutely exceptional trip
[Music
] new caledonia had reserved
so many surprises for us in the last few
weeks and this day was not going to
be left out with
a pygmy seahorse
barely visible in the Gorgonians
[Music]
With so many iman species vying
for our attention this
tiny seahorse no bigger than a
fingernail was a Hindu reminder of the expanse
th  t of the very complexity of these
ecosystems
[Music]
the
once our dive was over
we returned to noumea
we looked at our samples
and gave us
the quarter of an hour
it's good to take
[Music]
m
now our mistrust the reefs
moving away from new caledonia
are one of the best examples of cons
intact coral systems on our
planet
the new caledonian government has already
established a vast marine park in the
coral sea get full protection
for these stories  customs officers would not
only be beneficial for the people of
new caledonia but also for
the whole world
it would represent a hope and an
example of a country which not only
understands the beauty and the value of its
natural environment but which
also takes action and  protects it
for future generations
times to lobby a list of future
[Music]
g